look at eye level
this is me in the middle of crossing one
of the weirdest borders i've ever
crossed
it's this one it divides china from
china and it took me two hours to get
through
this border is weird not only because it
separates the same country into two
but also because it has an expiration
date july
1st 2047. until then
china has promised to stay out to let
hong kong
be highly autonomous hence the border
but the government of china doesn't
really want to wait until 2047.
they're ready to start erasing this
border now making hong
kong a proper part of china and one of
the ways they're doing that
is this huge bridge yeah i know this
isn't really the best shot
so here's a solution
[Music]
the drone doesn't even have a microphone
but even still i couldn't help but say
take a look at this bridge as it was
flying away
but seriously take a look at this bridge
aina has unveiled the world's largest
sea crossing bridge
it's 55 kilometers that's 34 miles
the longest sea crossing in the world
the bridge connects
hong kong with macau and mainland china
i always call this
some sort of umbilical cord between hong
kong and china
that they want something physical for
you to
register in your head that hong kong is
part of china so this bridge
and a bunch of other recent developments
in hong kong are bringing up a lot of
questions
of what is hong kong who does it really
belong to
and what happens when you erase a border
it's june 4th which is the anniversary
of the tiananmen square massacre
there are hundreds of thousands of
people here in tiananmen square
in the history of communist china there
has never been anything
like this on june 4th 1989 pro-democracy
protesters were marching on beijing's
tiananmen square
calling for the end of single-party rule
in china
they were then brutally massacred
hundreds were killed
the troops have been firing
indiscriminately sparking the end of any
sort of
widespread democracy movement in china
they've just turned off all the lights
in this park
[Music]
every year the residents of hong kong
hold a vigil to commemorate the people
killed in that massacre this is
something that's not allowed in mainland
china
but in recent years this vigil has
become more personal to these people
and that's because they are feeling a
new level of influence from
china but wait isn't hong kong already a
part of china
technically yes hong kong belongs to
china
but you sure wouldn't think so by
looking at this border that i'm at right
now
okay i made it into china i mean
technically i was already in china but
now i'm
like really in china
so how did it get like this
britain and china fought a couple of
wars over trade in the 1800s and britain
eventually took over hong kong as a
colony
at the time this was a mainly empty
rocket group of islands
in southern china under british rule
hong kong's population and economy
exploded and even though hong kong's
population was
mainly made up of immigrants from china
it became a very different society than
mainland china which was undergoing a
communist revolution
one of the treaties that china and
britain signed said that hong kong would
be a british colony for
99 years which meant that the agreement
would officially expire in 1997.
as that expiration date drew nearer
china and great britain
started to talk about what this is going
to look like
britain acknowledges that when the lease
runs out in 1997 on most of the
territory
the whole of hong kong will revert to
china
let's finish talking about this stuff up
there
if you go up to the 69th floor in this
building in the chinese border city of
shenzhen
you'll find a life-size wax sculpture of
this moment in the mid-80s
when the leaders from china and great
britain sat around and negotiated the
terms of handing over hong kong to china
and they came to this agreement that
britain would give over hong kong
peacefully to china
under the condition that hong kong would
be able to retain its way of life
legal system their economic system have
freedom of speech
freedom press freedom of association
these are fundamental freedoms freedom
of religious worship
these are fundamental freedoms and they
must continue
china agreed they said they would let
them be independent and govern
themselves for 50 years while they kind
of adjusted to chinese rule
50 years beyond 1997. and so this was
the agreement that they came to
it's called the one country two systems
model and it was kind of unprecedented
okay let's head back to hong kong
see a margaret see a deng
so even after hong kong was handed back
to china in 1997
this border that i'm now biking to stuck
around it remained
exactly how it was and this border
became
highly symbolic of the fact that yes
this is china
but it was kind of its own country at
the same time
governed with its own values and its own
system
that is different than china that is in
opposition to china in some ways
perhaps the most overt symbol of chinese
sovereignty
is this army barracks behind me it's the
chinese army
and so even though these soldiers can't
leave the barracks or do any sort of
enforcement activities within hong kong
they're still here in the central area
of the city
and they serve as a very powerful symbol
of the fact that this is
chinese territory this is chinese
sovereignty but these soldiers won't be
confined for much longer the borders
around their barracks
as well as this border up north are
quickly dissolving
china has committed to respect hong
kong's autonomy until 2047
and for the first decade after the
handover they respected that promise
what you have to understand is that hong
kong was easily
china's most economically productive
city in the early 90s right before the
handover
this one city's economy was more than a
quarter the size
of china's entire economy and so it
makes sense why china would agree
to these terms to keep hong kong happy
and economically free
but then things changed look at the
explosive development of these chinese
cities in recent years
these are china's mega cities these
cities eventually
eclipsed hong kong as the economic
powerhouse of china
shenzhen this town that shares the
border with hong kong is a perfect
example of this
the place went from a small fishing
village of around 30 000 people
to a super productive economic
powerhouse of over 10 million people
in just a few decades
[Music]
hong kong went from making up 27 of
chinese gdp in the early 90s
down to just 3 today and suddenly
hong kong once the economic powerhouse
of china and the gateway to the west
became much less economically relevant
and soon the chinese government didn't
have the same incentives to respect hong
kong's autonomy
so now you begin to see a flood of
chinese influence in this city
let's go see if we can catch the five
o'clock news
in recent years the evening news
broadcast has started with the national
anthem of china
playing under a promo video that shows
hong kongers enthusiastically
participating in traditional chinese
customs
the message is very clear that hong kong
is a part of china whether they like it
or not on top of that
the language of the evening news is
mandarin the official language of china
but in hong kong they don't speak
mandarin they speak cantonese
then they say if you want to kill a city
you kill is language first and we speak
cantonese here there are actually some
professors in
hong kong and china telling us that oh
cantonese is actually not our mother
tongue not hong kong is mother's house
cantonese is actually just a dialect of
chinese a chinese
the chinese government tried to get
teachers to use this textbook to teach
hong kong children the basics about
china
but looking into the book you see that
it's more of an advertisement for
china's style of government than an
introduction to it
the chinese system is the ideal type so
maori multi-party uh rivalry will make
the people suffer
because about all these four points
about how bad the united states
is multi-party systems create government
shutdowns
they're basically pointing to that as
the reason why a multi-party system like
that of the united states
is deeply flawed and really bad for the
people
in 2014 china took it one step too far
the chinese government was trying to
control who could run for hong kong's
election
in an effort to secure a pro-china
candidate this really touched a nerve
for the locals because
this was their democratic process
something that china promised they would
stay out of
so people immediately took to the
streets in protest
starting here in this park
[Applause]
i took the taxi from my home to here on
the
night what was it like down here that
night
we were in a standoffish situation
and suddenly they used um
tear gas the first drop of
tear gas just dropped right in front of
my eyes
we were holding umbrella
trying to prevent pepper sprays
i remember that itchy painful feeling oh
my gosh
i saw hong kong people joining uniting
together against
against the central government and
fighting for their rights
this protest and the subsequent movement
that came up around it
is known as the umbrella movement
you would say oh what's the point of
fighting when you're bombed to lose
they're so big you're so small for the
record
we need to fight we're not taking things
lying down
the protest didn't change the chinese
government's mind
and it didn't immediately change
anything in hong kong but this spectacle
of young people rising up to defend
their rights from the central government
of china
did spark a political awakening among
the many in the city who had never
before paid attention
and i think post umbrella movement was
the first time that the middle class
came out and voted
in droves and voted for the opposition
force but for the first time like
you know people sort of like ourselves
started caring
look at this graph that shows how hong
kongers identify themselves
either as chinese or hong konger in the
early days after the handoff
as china respected the one party two
systems arrangement
you can see how hong kongers slowly
became more and more comfortable
identifying themselves as chinese
but since then with the growing
influence from the chinese government
you can see this line reverse course
residents of hong kong who identify
themselves as chinese
has almost hit a new all-time low the
umbrella movement
is a manifestation of this growing hong
kong identity
and the resistance to chinese government
influence china responded to the
umbrella movement with a new wave of
efforts to exert influence in this city
i'm standing outside the bookstore where
in 2015
five staff members disappeared
throughout the year
this bookstore was selling books that
were banned in china
that basically covered the sex lives and
the corruption scandals of high-ranking
chinese officials
and so one by one throughout 2015 people
who worked in these
in this bookstore disappeared no one
really knows where they went
one of them showed up a bit later on
chinese television
apologizing for what he did and
confessing to his crimes
[Music]
down
back here in victoria park these candle
holders stand as a symbol
of the fight for democracy against
china's single party rule
that was once a fight that happened far
away in beijing
but as this border has slowly been
erased these people now find themselves
engaged in that same fight
resisting a much more powerful china in
the struggle for their own democracy and
identity
[Music]
[Music]
you